hey everybody this is Gregory from deaf
University so I'm so excited to be on
free code camp today to teach you how to
become a blockchain developer I'm gonna
take you over the shoulder and teach you
how to write a theory of smart contracts
with a solidity programming language for
the blockchain and you don't even have
to know anything about solidity or
blockchain to follow along so I've
compiled this multi-part tutorial series
into one massive video for free code
camp
and you can follow along with the code
examples step-by-step on my website
there's an article that I'm gonna put a
link to down the description below
and finally if you're serious about
becoming a blockchain developer you need
to join my free training on my website
over at Daffy diversity comm forward
slash boot camp and I'll also put a link
to that down in the description below
solidity is the main programming
language for writing smart contracts on
the etherium blockchain it's a contract
oriented language which basically means
that you know smart contracts are the
main way that you organize code and like
store data and write all of your
programming logic and you know it's a
high-level language for implementing
these smart contracts it looks a lot
like JavaScript and you know Python and
C++ as you see right here and it's used
to run on the etherium virtual machine
which is basically you know the thing
that runs the code on the etherion
blockchain so solidity is statically
typed as opposed to a dynamically typed
language and it supports stuff like
inheritance libraries and lots of other
stuff so enough of talking about
solidity let's actually jump in and
start writing some solidity code this is
a website that allows you to write
solidity smart contracts in your browser
and you know it has a text editor here
and allows you to compile them and
deploy them and run them and that's
exactly what I'm going to use for this
tutorial you won't have to download
anything in your computer you won't have
to install anything you can just visit
this website to use remix and will write
the smart contracts that way so in order
to do that I'm gonna go over here to
this browser folder and you can see the
file browser over here this is some
basic smart contracts that come
pre-loaded inside of this IDE I'm just
going to create a new one here I think I
can just create a new file and this will
be a solidity file I will call it my
contract
and we're going to write a smart
contract inside of here I'll do this by
first declaring the version of solidity
that we want to use we just do that like
this we say pragma solidity and it means
a caret to specify a version greater
than the one we want to use and I'm
gonna say version 0.4 4.24 and I'm gonna
end each line like this with a semicolon
and next I'm actually gonna declare the
smart contract so before I do that I'll
explain a little bit more about what a
smart contract is you know smart
contract is code that gets executed on
the blockchain in this case this is
gonna be the etherium blockchain since
we're using you know solidity for the
etherium smart contract and this smart
contract is kind of be kind of like a
micro service out on the web it's going
to be accessible to everyone on the
blockchain they'll be able to you know
see this smart contract they'll be able
to use it they'll be able to read and
write data with it and actually you know
execute any code that we write inside of
here so it's gonna be public and that's
kind of why I call it like a micro
service it's more it's more than just a
class like in an object-oriented system
or something like that it's actually
something that's publicly accessible so
it's gonna look something like a class
though because that's how we're gonna
actually you know keep all the code
inside of here so I'll show you how to
do that
we'll call will start by saying contract
say my contract and I'm open this with
some curly braces and it'll notice that
the editor closes this automatically for
us which is really nice and what I'm
gonna do first is just show you how to
read and write a value from a variable
inside of here now like I said earlier
solidity is a statically typed language
so we're gonna actually have to declare
the type the data type of the variable
we want to store so in this case we're
just gonna store string and we'll
declare a string we'll say value now let
me explain something about this value
this value is going to represent you
know a variable that belongs to this
entire smart contract so this isn't like
a local variable it's at
a variable that this entire contract
will know about and what that means with
a smart contract is that data is
actually going to get stored on the
blockchain in storage so if we set this
value we're actually gonna be writing
data to the blockchain that's different
from a local variable that I might just
you know set inside of a function that
would be you know local to that function
scope and what you know disappear
instantly once that function is called
instead this value is actually going to
be you know stored on the blockchain so
let's create a way to us just read this
value so I can do this by writing a
function and solidity like this we just
start with the function keyword and I
say I'm just gonna call the function get
it's gonna get this value and we'll say
I'll just open the braces for now I'm
gonna write some more code here in a
second we can see some warnings coming
up but I'll fill this out more will say
just return value okay and that's a
really basic way to do this I'm gonna
add some more to this I'm gonna say this
is also public all right which basically
is setting the visibility of this
function that's that's called and
solidity is setting the visibility so
that knows this function can be called
by anyone who has access to the smart
contract on the blockchain not just
inside this contract so I'm also going
to set our term by you say returns a
string all right that makes our warning
disappear down here and I just tell
their function that we're always gonna
return a string datatype and we know
that's the same data type as value
because we declared it here now I'm also
gonna look at this warning down here
which says this function state
mutability can be restricted so
basically what this is saying is in
solidity now in this newest version
since we're not actually changing this
value we're not changing anything inside
this function we want to add additional
modifier here which just says view all
right and that makes that warning go
away so now I'm gonna set a new function
or write a new function that's called
set let's say function it's gonna allow
us to set this value say set
as a string I'll save value all right
and I'm also going to you know set the
visibility of this function when it call
it public which means that anyone will
be able to set this value on the
blockchain and I'll say value equals
this value that we're passing in all
right let me explain that I'm using
value as an underscore here because I
want to differentiate between this value
that's getting passed in and the value
that's referenced here now inside of
here you know this value without an
underscore is referencing this you know
state variable that we set up earlier
that's actually getting stored to the
blockchain
and this value solidity knows that it's
just a local variable because I passed
it in and I you know prepended it with
an underscore like this and also notice
that I declared the data type of the
function argument we need that inside
solidity because it needs to know the
type of the data that's getting passed
in all right and now we have a way to
actually read this value and set it the
next thing I'm going to show you is how
to set this value whenever you read
deploy the smart contract or whenever
it's generated it for the first time and
I'm going to do this with the
constructor function so if you're
familiar with other programming
languages where you might write you know
classes dozen like that you might be
familiar with a constructor function
which is basically a function that's
called whenever this contract is
instantiated or in this case it's gonna
be whatever the contract is created or
whenever the smart contract is deployed
to the blockchain and in the newer
versions of solidity we do that like
this we say constructor and we just you
know say it's public
and we can you know write code inside of
this constructor that gets called
whenever this contract is created and
we'll say you know value we'll just set
it as you know my value
all right there we go so that's a
complete smart contract that you know
sets this value whenever it's deployed
so it will have some sort of default
value and then we'll have you know some
functions that allow us to read that
value from the blockchain and then we'll
have us a function that allows us to
create that value as well so now I can
go to this tab over here and remix and I
can compile it we can select the
compiler version and I'm gonna say let's
see here 0.425 will start to compile it
and see what happens
all right and now what I'm gonna do is
actually run the smart contract you'll
see some options over here I'm just
going to say JavaScript virtual machine
which basically what that's gonna do is
give us a test blockchain in the browser
so we don't have to connect to a
blockchain of any kind we can just you
know compile this and run it and deploy
it inside of our browser which is pretty
cool and it's gonna give us some you
know free aetherium accounts over here I
don't worry if you don't quite
understand what all these values mean
just yet that's okay I can explain those
more but for now we're gonna just keep
my contract and we're gonna deploy it
all right there we go it's deployed so
now what I can do is click on this
little down arrow here and we can see
the functions that are available to us
in the smart contract we can see the set
function and the get function you know
these are the functions that we created
over here the set function is going to
allow us to update it and the get
functions allow us to get it
so I'll click get and we should probably
see the value that we created inside the
constructor we set it here so let's get
it all right there we go it's my value
and we can see some activity in this log
down here we can see that we it was a
call to my contract get
and now we'll set it so I'm going to
enter the quotations for the string and
I'm going to say new value
alright let's click set
all right and we can see that worked so
you can see the transaction history over
here let's get the value all right it's
new value there we go that's a complete
smart contract that allows you to get
instead of value on the blockchain now
let me explain what's going on here this
is a list of transactions that are
occurring on the etherium blockchain so
the etherium blockchain is made up of
you know bundles of records that are
chained together into blocks that are
make up the blockchain and you know the
basic units of all those blocks are
these transactions so we can see
transaction receipts we can actually
click the down arrow here we can see all
the details of those transaction
receipts and I've got other videos in
this channel that kind of talk about
that in detail if you want to know more
about that just feel free to look for
those all right that's it guys that's
how you can write your first smart
contract and the solidity programming
language again that's supposed to be
just a high-level overview of solidity
and how to get started writing your
first smart contracts and using the
programming language itself and using
the remix IDE in your browser to get
started easily without having to
download any tools or anything like that
the first thing I want to do in this
video is actually update the smart
contract code that we wrote in the last
video to support the newest version of
the solidity programming language which
is 0.5 dot 1 I believe now you can
actually see the compiler version number
has changed and in the last video you
know we wrote this smart contract and
there's some actually some compilation
errors you can see over here on the
right so you have to update this code to
support the newest version of the
solidity programming language and I want
to go I wanted to go ahead and do this I
wanted to go ahead and support the new
version of solidity so that when I make
more videos in this series they'll be up
the day you'll have the newest version
so let's do what we need to do we can
read the error it says basically the
data location must be memory and that's
actually the error in both cases so all
we need to do in this case is actually
just return memory here and then
whenever we're passing in the value a
string we actually need to put memory
here as well all right actually that
needs to be before value my fault and
now we there's go away so we will select
the newest compiler version we'll say
let's do the latest complete version is
0.5 dot 1 start to compile and hopefully
the compilation will work yeah it worked
so let's go to run and we'll deploy and
see if it worked
let's look at the value yep it worked
awesome
now let's move on to the next part of
this tutorial where we'll actually cover
the content for this video which is
gonna be you know the basic data types
and data structures and solidity and how
you can use them when you're developing
your own smart contracts so I will
change some values in here to kind of
show you what that is the first thing I
want to talk about are you know the
different ways we can work with through
state variables right so the first thing
I want to mention is you know we had
this string value here that we had
declared and we set it here inside this
set function and we had this getter
function where we read that value right
so solidity has a shortcut where I don't
even need this function I can actually
just read this string value for free I
can actually get this function for free
take this out and just declare this
public that's that's declaring the
visibility of the state variable here
actually public goes before so I'll save
that and I'll compile it you know run it
and we'll see that a get getter function
called value the same name is the state
variable was exposed to us by the smart
contract and we can see it works just
the same way as the other function did
so that's a really nice way to save
yourself reminding extra code you can
just get that function for free exposed
to the public interface at the smart
contract
whenever you store your state variables
that way okay so the next thing I want
to talk about inside of here is actually
you know we can set this as a default
value we don't necessarily have to put
you know my value here in the
constructor you just say this alright I
could take this away oops take this away
and we will run that again let's just
clear this out deploy all right we can
actually sorry when you compile it first
boil it again get the value we can see
is my value we can also set this value
as a constant if we don't want it to
change
you know if we don't want to allow a
user to set this value we want to stay
the same
we can just say constant all right and
that actually declares a constant we had
to remove this function we can't update
this value at all so let it you won't
let us do that so we could just do that
I'll deploy us again and we can still
see our values here as my value so you
know that's how you would add a constant
to your state variables or make your
state variables constant now let's look
at some other data types and solidity
let's just change this name we'll call
this like string value
alright let's just deploy that we can
see this instance here again string
value alright it's my value now let's
explore some other data types we can say
boolean type will say bool a public is
equal to I'm gonna remove this constant
for now my pool equals true alright so
this just accepts true or false we can
deploy that see this my pool all right
it's true string value is my value say
or my string just save that just for fun
and we can also see that you know we
support data types like integers so
integers can be signed or unsigned so
what does that mean well we can do a
default int which would be public my int
goes 1 right so we can deploy this and
see let's actually just clear this out
it's alright apply this and see my int
equal to one so the difference between
an int and au nth or an unsigned integer
is that an integer can be signed in a or
sorry yeah an integer can be signed and
a you nth can be unsigned so what does
that mean well basically an int can be
negative so I can do minus one all right
and deploy that that's a sign integer it
has a sign in front of it it can be
positive or negative and a unit can't so
I'll deploy that clear these out and see
my you int all right and my int all
right yes a negative one can work for an
int and they can't do negatives on
unsigned integers you can also specify
the amount of bytes or bits in an
integer so we can say you int 8 blick
goes in my unit 8 sorry because like all
right oops
let's do a small number yes
and because he might you an eight
alright and so if we do you int here it
defaults to 256 I believe you meant 256
public my unit okay so that gives you a
basic overview of all those basic
datatypes i don't want to bore you with
all the pedantic details of this kind of
stuff but this is helpful to know i feel
like the next thing i want to show you
is an enum so what is an enum and how do
you use it well an enum is basically an
enumerated list that's gonna allow us to
keep track of you know set list of
things in our contract so I'll show you
what that means so basically I can
declare anything like this they'll say a
new state and I'll give it some options
here I'll say waiting ready active
alright and this is gonna allow us to
keep a list of these three states inside
the smart contract I'll be able to
reference this to see what the current
state is and it'll give us some options
whenever we're updating this state and
like checking against this so I'll show
you an example it'll actually store this
like this will declare state public
state this alright so basically this is
going to give us a public we're going to
be able to access this publicly with
that getter so inside of here I'll do a
constructor I'll say constructor I was a
public as a state equals state active
all right so I'll go ahead and set the
default state to active right so
actually let's do this let's do waiting
and then I'll say I'll create a function
to activate it yes a activate
as a public state equals state dot
active so we can actually choose sorry
we can choose this value out of this um
list and update the state to that value
all right so whenever we call this
function it'll change the state to the
active state and let's get a function
that checks to see if the state is
active will say function is active and
we'll say public view returns bool all
right we'll say return state equal to
state active sense will do inside of
here we'll just check to see if the
state currently is active all right so
let's see if you have any errors looks
good
I will compile this alright we run
deploy and all right let's check the
state so is to stay active all right no
it's false so that's that's true it's
not active it's in waiting
so let's actually check the state so
state is zero so zero corresponds to the
first item in this list 0 which is
waiting and I'll click activate alright
so actually called the activate function
which you know updates the state to
active let's see if it's active yep
it's true and let's check the state so
now the state is 2 which is 0 1 2 all
right so that's an idea of how you use a
news let's look at the next concept that
I want to show you the next comment I'll
show you is let's do those two structs
so structs are basically a way for you
to define your own data structures
inside solidity well do that like this
we'll say what create a struct right
here we'll call it person this is a
struct person and we'll give it some
look at some some characteristics with a
string first name and string a last name
okay so basically what's going on here
is this allows us to basically model you
know our own sort of arbitrary data I'm
just gonna model a person with this
truck that's gonna have a few attributes
it's gonna have a first name attribute
that's going to be a string and a last
name attribute that's also going to be a
string and we can put these struts
inside of like a raise and mappings and
things like that I'll show you that here
in a minute inside this video but for
now just know that we declare that we've
defined this new data type person inside
the smart contract with a struct that's
gonna have a first name and a last name
okay so let's actually create a function
that allows us to instantiate a new
person create a new one and we'll
actually keep track of a bunch of these
person's trucks inside of a people array
all right so let's do that like this
let's say let's keep track of a bunch of
different persons that we can create new
ones
we'll say person so being array public
people all right so let's see what's
happening here people is the state
variable here and its inner its public
so we can read it outside the smart
contract and it's an array here of these
data type person all right so we declare
the data type first justperson which we
defined here the struct it's an array
that you know contains these person's
trucks it's public and it's stored up
with the people very state variable so
we can add people to this array or
person's trucks to this array like this
okay the function is a function add
person it's a string this is a solidity
5 update memory or 0.5 sorry a first
name and then we'll say string memory
last name was it public
and we'll do this inside here so that
people push so push is you know a
function we can call an arrays to add a
new item at the the 2d array and we'll
push a new instance of this person
struct so we can create an instance like
this we just call person right and we
pass in these attributes so I say first
name
oops sorry name and last name
all right
and what we can do here is y-yeah we've
added it it's going to do it so let's
just let's just compile this and run it
deploy this all right so let's see what
happens so people it's going to add the
person
and person I'm sorry see with first name
the first name will be DAP last name
would be University
well a person okay awesome so that
didn't give us any errors now how do we
read this person out of here that's a
good question so we added this person to
an array but this function you know
whatever we call this person or this
artist people function it's not gonna
return the entire array of people that's
because this is you know we don't know
the size of this arrays and solidity and
we have an array of unknown size it's
not going to return the entire array so
basically we need to reference the
person by ID so whenever we get this
function it expects an argument which is
gonna be the index of the person inside
this array so for example we know we
added one person in there so we will add
people and we'll say zero all right
there you go
DAP University so what happens if we
reference you know a person that doesn't
exist a person you know a one people
it's gonna give us an error it's an in
doubt opcode error that's because
there's no one in there at position one
so how how do we like you know how do we
fix that problem just keep track of that
like this so basically we would keep an
internal count of the people we'd say
something like this you int 256 people
count okay and that's gonna basically
have this a counter cash that will
increment every time a person to added
so we can say something like people
count plus equals 1 all right let me do
that after I guess
all right say then deploy
and now we can actually make this public
it was sighs before
that's right again
so now we can add the person tap
University
at person and we could see people count
is one so we would do one - that people
alright DAP University we do one - that
because it's zero based index which
means the first item you know as an
index zero and the second ones that
index one etc etc the next thing I want
to show you is how to do a similar
concept here but model it a little
differently so instead of using an array
we're actually gonna use a mapping so
what is a mapping a mapping is basically
like an associative array so instead of
having you know just an array and we
know the each index of the item in the
array we can actually associate a - of
values so that's let's look a hash table
or a hash map or a hash and other
programming languages that you might be
familiar with or basically you can
reference things by you know a key value
its key key value pair so instead of
having people like this instead of being
an array I'm gonna change it down here
I'm gonna say this is gonna be mapping
mapping you int person
okay so you int is going to be the key
and the person's going to be a value so
this mapping is like I said an
associative array that's going to take a
key value pair the key is going to be an
unsigned integer we'll treat this like
an ID so it'd be kind of like our
database lookup where we have an ID and
then a record so this is gonna return
kind of like a record like a person
record or a person struct in this case
it'll be public and it'll be people and
it is kind of a fair comparison to
compare this to a database because you
know we're watching kind of is a big
database and these trucks are you know
getting stored and storage on the
blockchain with this mapping and is a
person string first name last name it
will do the add person so I mean you
modify this function I will still think
the first name will still look the last
name but we're going to put this in the
mapping instead of the array some of
these people count back up here we're
gonna want to keep track of this they're
stuck we did earlier so we know how many
people are in this mapping but we'll add
it to the mapping like this we'll say
people people count this will be your ID
so if it starts at zero which it will do
this all right people count plus equals
one that'd be the new ID of the person
that's going to go in here
so this will be person number one the
first time we add this we'll say this is
going to be a new person it'll be we'll
give it an we'll give this an ID we'll
say you nth
i D okay people count
and then we'll say first name
and then last name
all right and we'll take this out all
right let's see if that worked
clear this out before the contract
so
first name is DAP University
that person okay so see people count is
one now and we'll go to people this time
it won't be based on the array index
it'll actually be on the ID so we can
actually reference person 1 all right
we'll do people 1 there we go
deputy bursting so let me explain a
couple more things about structs while
we're here you know we need to keep
track of this people count because
there's no way to know the size this
mapping and solidity basically any key
that doesn't have a value set for it's
going to turn a default value which is
going to be like an empty struct here so
if I do like you know person no 10
or like 909 people seems you can return
default values so or the default values
for the struct person the ID for a you
int is gonna be 0 and then these blank
strings for first name and last name so
that's why we need to have a person
count so if you were gonna use this like
as a data storage and you want to like
show all the people or all persons and
you're in your people mapping and your
app or something like that ring for the
smart contract you want to know that how
many are actually in there and you want
to do that with a counter cash so that
way you know if you wanted to basically
like the same thing with those variable
sized arrays like if you wanted to get
all the items you need to first make a
call to find out how many there are and
that's what to use the counter cash for
and then you basically create a loop to
read out each one one by one so yeah
it's it can be kind of a pain but that's
sort of just the state of things and
what you have to do
I'm gonna go ahead and pick up where we
left off in the last video I'm gonna use
this you know my contract that we built
where we added a person person struct to
this mapping of people if you haven't
seen that last video go ahead check that
out
it's not necessary but you can probably
follow along with this video if you want
to what I'm gonna do now is show you a
little more about these modifiers like
public and things like that I think we
talked about that in the first video but
I'm gonna go just a little further so
what I can do is you know show you
another modifier which is basically like
internal so that's different from public
you know public is a function that can
be called you know the public interface
at the smart contract you can see you
know the public functions listed here on
the side so going create a private
function or an internal function excuse
me you'll say function we're just going
to take this people count and wrap it in
its own function to show you how that
works
we'll say increment counts we'll just
make this a function and we can call it
internal that's a different modifier I
will just take this people account I'll
paste it inside of here alright and
we'll just say increment count call that
function and we'll run it
see the smart contract will add the
person will say DAP oops
DAP University
and I'll click add person and there we
go it incrementing the count you can see
the people count has been changed you'd
say Joe hello
and the cow has changed so that's a way
that you can you know use other
functions that are gonna be internal and
we can see this increment count function
isn't added to this list over here it's
not exposed to you know things outside
of the smart contract external collars
can't use it so that's an example of you
know other you know types of visibility
of functions and solidity let's talk
about function modifiers so we can add
you know more you know words and terms
to the end of this function to change
how it behaves and I'll show you an
example so we're gonna create our own
custom modifier actually inside of this
smart contract so that only certain
people can call this add person function
all right so I'm gonna do is basically
you know make this smart contract have
an owner or like an admin and we're
gonna say the only the owner can call
this add person function and any other
account connected to the network
you know whenever they try to you know
add a person they won't be able to and
that'll show you how we can add an extra
modifier to this function to make that
happen basically we'll just add a
modifier that's the only the owner of
this smart contract can do that so first
we need to actually it'll look like this
will say only owner that's what the
modifier would look like now this only
owner motor fire doesn't exist yet so
let's go ahead and create it alright so
we'll do that like this first we need to
keep track of an owner we'll say the
owner is you know address
I'm not sure if we talked about this in
the data types video but you know an
address is a data type in size of
solidity you know I can address that's
on the network and account so this will
be the address we're just gonna declare
it here we're not gonna set it just yet
we can set it like this we can do it
inside the constructor well actually
nothing to that just yet so that will be
the owner we basically just create a
modifier like this we say modifier it's
the only owner it's like a function and
what we'll do inside of here is write
the logic that makes sure that you know
whoever you know calling the smart
contract is the owner so that's what
we're defining you're only owner and
only owner so how do we do that how do
we say the person who's calling this
function is the owner of this smart
contract well we're going to compare it
to this owner right here but how do we
know who's calling the function well
solidity has a global keyword called MSG
which basically stands for the function
metadata that's passed in and we're not
actually going to pass in any metadata
here it's going to be implied so
basically we have access to msu got
sender and this is basically a special
you know thing inside solidity that
tells us the account you knows address
who called the function and basically we
can just say you know is this person the
owner we can just you know compare
equality of the person who's calling the
function with this owner that we're
gonna store here in a second all right
and if they're not we actually want to
throw an error all right so this is
going to show you another concept and
solidity about error handling so we can
throw an error and solidity like you
know I think earlier we had some errors
happen like here's an error we actually
want to trigger an error if this person
you know it's not the owner we want to
we want to revert the transaction now if
you that like this we say require
sorry Ms you got senders equal to the
owner so basically anything inside of
this require if it evaluates to true
then this passes if it evaluates to
false then this will throw an error we
basically are saying require that
whatever you put inside of here is true
all right and then after this we can
basically just do this all right
and now our only only Audemar fire is
complete
it's basically now we have this modifier
that's you know defined here and we add
it here and basically say if the person
who is you know calling this function is
the owner then you know we can actually
run this function and they're not we're
going to you know create a failure we're
going to revert the transaction and also
whoever's doing this you know whatever
like this code won't run so they won't
pay this gas fee all right so now we
need to set the owner and I'm just going
to do that inside a constructor we'll
use msg sender as well say function
instructor
and we'll just open this curly braces
and we'll say owner equals to MSG SSRI
msg sender sorry I don't need the
function keyword here
and we all seem to make this public all
right so I'll save that so whenever you
deploy the smart contract like that you
know this constructor gets run and the
MSG dot sender is actually the account
that deploys the smart contract and
they're gonna get set to this owner
state variable write this address owner
and basically that same you know address
is the only person that's gonna be able
to call this add person function all
right and if they yeah this code will
run and we will add a person and if we
switch accounts to some other account
over here then it won't work so let's
just try that I deploy this
we will you know deploy with this
account so let's change to that account
and we'll add the person actually I
don't know if it deployed that a counter
now let's try it again
so make sure on the first account will
deploy all right we'll add a person will
say adapt University
I had the person all right let's see
here all right it worked
your people count as one now we'll say
you know Joe Blow and will change
accounts to this one don't try to call
it again add person and we see as fails
and the people count has not changed at
all so it worked we've kept track of the
owner and we say only owner can do it
now we're here I'm gonna show you a
little code formatting that I like to do
sometimes this is getting kind of long
and sometimes you know if you like me
and you have a text editor with a whole
bunch of panes open I'd to keep my
columns kind of short sometimes
especially with solidity and it kind of
makes it easier to maintain these
functions when the arguments are getting
long and using git and things like that
sometimes I will just break these up
like this
all right and then I'll actually put the
modifiers if you have a bunch of
modifier sometimes this makes it easier
to read and also when I'm writing my own
salinity source code I don't use two
spaces I don't use four but yeah that's
sometimes how I break these functions up
so I can see the function name and then
the arguments then I can see the
modifiers and then I can actually see
the code that gets executed inside here
and I can make your smart contracts kind
of long but sick and me sometimes this
will catch you if you have too many and
if you have three visibility and
modifiers on here sometimes it can be
kind of tricky so I like doing this
alright so next I'm gonna show you how
to work with time and solidity okay so
what we can do is basically compare time
and solidity and instead of this saying
only owner can do this let's say you can
only call this function if a certain
time has passed so let's pretend like
you know this is a contract that is only
open at a certain time so we'll say
instead of only owner will say only
while open only while open all right and
this opening state is going to be
determined by a time
so once we've passed a certain time in
history in the future then we'll let you
call this function if it's before that
we won't do it so that's really useful
if like you're building a crowd sale or
something like that that has an opening
time ranking I see oh smart contract and
you say hey we can only let you
contribute ether like after you know the
first of the month
well you just figure out what time that
is and say hey you know if you make a
contribution before then we'll throw an
error so I'll say only while open all
right
and instead of requiring that MSG that
Center is the owner
all right well actually gonna just take
this out
we're gonna say we're going to make sure
that the current time is in the future
beyond a certain like opening time so
let's do you int 256 opening time all
right
so how do we do this well we need to set
this opening times somehow alright so
the opening time is actually expressed
in seconds and you know inside solidity
or these unit time Sandra expressed in
seconds inside solidity and you know
seconds of what well it's it's epic time
which if you're not familiar with that
it's a concept in computer science
that's like the epic is a is a specific
time I can't remember the actual date
it's like a date in the sixties or
seventies like that and basically we
just add seconds since that point in
time of history so this is the current
epoch timestamp is this many seconds
since the epoch time I guess she's
probably a link here we can read more
about that yeah the UNIX epoch clock
yeah I'm sure you can get on Wikipedia
and figure all that out but basically
this is the current epoch time is
changing so we use these seconds values
so this is like the current you know
epoch timestamp will say this alright so
this is how we could set this and it's
you know you went 256 it's gonna store
this big number of seconds since that
time stamp and that's gonna be our
opening time and so how do we compare
that to now so how do you get now and
solidity well there's no perfect way to
do it but the best way is to get the
current blocks timestamp all right so
how do we do that well just like MSG
there's a global variable and getting's
and solidity called block dot and we can
say block timestamp all right and we can
say is the block dot timestamp is it
greater than or equal to the opening
time
all right so basically if it's after the
opening time we're gonna let you call
this function and if it's not then we
won't all right so let's give this a try
I'm gonna update this timestamp let's
refresh it you'll see this is the
current one I'll paste this in here so
15 I'm gonna add 60 seconds so a minute
so I'm gonna deploy this and it will be
it shouldn't work right now so we can
try to call add person now I will try to
add DAP University
okay well add person and we'll see that
it reverted okay and now we can check
the timestamp we're not there yet so
I'll just pause the video wait for this
to past 75 I think that's the actual
time
yeah 75 all right I'll pause the video
pause the video give it as plenty of
time or pass the timestamp you can see
the 793 and we're at 775
so let's deploy it again oh actually
it's not deployed again let's just do
Joe Blow a person and it worked so
that's how you can use time and solidity
you can get the current time and set a
time value with seconds and so that's
what I'm gonna call today guys
I hope you all liked this video let me
know how you're enjoying these solidity
videos let me know if I missed anything
or there something you want to learn or
if you're just not liking then that's
okay too just let me know down the
comments section below
let's use the same my contract example
that we've been you know using
throughout this tutorial series and you
don't necessarily have to have been
following along with every video in this
series you can kind of pick back up with
this one probably see yeah let's go
ahead and jump in and start programming
what I'm going to show you first is how
to write a function that accepts ether
so basically like how can we send ether
in when we call function and do stuff
with it so I'll show you how to do that
first we'll create a function called by
token say by token and this function is
gonna kind of emulate what happens in an
IC o---- like a crowd sale or a pre sale
or something like that on aetherium when
you're buying a RC 20 tokens I'm not
gonna like code out an entire ERC 20
tokens smart contract right here or you
know cut out a crowd sale smart contract
I've got several other tutorials that
show you how to you know code romo
cryptocurrency on etherium with you know
bill ter c 20 tokens step-by-step and a
real world crowd sale things like that
so you can check out those other videos
if you're interested but what we're
gonna do is basically create this
function called buy token it's gonna
simulate what happens it's not gonna do
everything but it'll least give you an
idea of how that works so we'll call
this you know buy token and inside here
what we basically want to do is buy a
token and we also want to send ether to
the wallet so what's going to happen is
someone's going to call this function
and they're gonna send ether when they
call this function and when they do
we're gonna issue them a token and then
the wallet is actually going to receive
the ether that they sent and when they
call this function so I'll show you how
to do that first I'm gonna create a way
to track the tokens and basically all
this is gonna do is you know track this
person's balance so why use a mapping
for that I'll say mapping and again if
you didn't check that out for the other
videos the mapping is like an
associative array where we have key
value pairs
so we'll say an address will be the key
and the value will be an unsigned
integer
all right and this will be public all
right this will give us a function for
free that allow us to read this value
and we'll just call this balances so
what we'll do and when we buy a token
and we'll basically just say balances of
whoever called this function so if you
remember from the last videos in this
series we we get that value with MSG
that's cinder this is the account that's
calling this function and we will just
increment this count by one now this is
not really fancy you know we're
basically just saying whenever you call
this function you're gonna buy one token
we're not using a rate of redemption or
anything like that this is just to kind
of show you how this works this is not
very sophisticated but basically they'll
just increment your balance you know
inside this token contract by one
whatever we do that we want to transfer
funds that are sent in with this smart
contract to a wallet all right so how do
we do that well first we keep track of a
wallet
we'll just declare a state variable here
it'll say address wallet
and we want to send funds to this wallet
okay it would do that like this and I'm
actually gonna show you something in a
minute that's gonna be a solidity 0.5
update so if you've been using previous
version solidity we have to make a
change here I'll go back to that in a
minute but anyways let's transfer funds
to this wallet we'll do that like this
so we'll say wallet transfer and we want
to transfer in the funds that are sent
by this function
sorry transfer the funds that are sent
in by this function to this wallet so
how do we do that well how do we
actually know what the the value is it's
getting sent in well just like MSG
that's sender you know MSG has another
property called value so we can say MSG
value alright and that's gonna tell us
exactly how much ether or whey is sent
in by the person who's sitting this
function so I'll show you how that works
so well that's going to do is take the
each of that sent and with this you know
function call and transfer it to this
wallet right here now there's this is
not complete there's a lot of things
that actually need to change in order
for this to work properly you can see
these X's over here these you know
compiler errors so the first thing we
need to do is set a wallet let's do that
inside a constructor we'll do that we'll
ever to deploy the smart contract
so we'll say constructor
we'll say address wallet was a public
and we'll say while it is just equal to
the wall we pass in
all right so we're still getting errors
now let's see what they are the first
thing you need to do in order to make
this function except ether well actually
first we need to make it public so that
people can call it and I say public all
right so now people will actually able
to call this function and send ether n
stuff like that and in order for people
to in order for this to accept ether we
have to add another modifier here which
is payable all right and if we don't do
that this won't allow us to send ether
in with the transaction so this is how
we declare that this function will
accept ether okay now here's a new
solidity update it requires explicitness
whenever you're declaring an address
that can accept either in setup smart
contract and we do that like this we say
address payable wallet all right
and then likewise we say address payable
wallet whenever we pass this function in
the constructor all right so that should
be a working implementation and we want
to see so let's deploy a smart contract
and try it out I will you know take one
of these addresses and it will take the
second address here in the list and
we'll use that as the wallet will
actually check its balance here a second
so we'll deploy smart contract we need
to pass in a wallet whatever deploy just
paste this in good deploy all right
looks like we're successful let's try to
do the by token function okay she's
gonna buy one token for us so I'll make
sure we've got the first account the
list selected by token all right looks
like I'm successful let's check the
balance of this oops actually paste it
in the wrong address paste it in the
second address so let's try the balance
again all right it's one all right now
all that did was actually transfer you
know all that did was by token it didn't
actually transfer ether to the wallet
and that's we want to show so in order
to like sand ether in and actually
transfer funds to the wallet we would do
that like this we change this to ether
I'm gonna send one ether in with this
transaction whenever we call the by
tokens function we'll do after this
account and we'll click by token all
right boom so let's check the balance
again all right the balances - now let's
see what happened we can see that the
ether value decreased here from you know
ninety nine point nine to ninety eight
point nine it actually took ether out of
our wallet because we sent it in with
the transaction and we can see that the
second account in the list which I used
as the wallet whenever deployed has been
credited with that ether so our smart
contract worked it actually sent you
know the value that we sent in with this
to that account alright so the next
thing I want to show you is how you can
create basically a fallback function and
solidity this is what's called
at least that's what I've seen it called
I'm not sure what
official name is but basically it's
going to be like a default function that
you can wrap this in so the whatever you
just send either to the smart contract
and execute the function you'll see that
a lot like icos
where you know they have an address
posted and they say hey sent either to
that smart contract and it'll actually
buy the tokens for you now this is just
a kind of pseudocode implementation
again of like a purchase function you
know real ico function functionality
would be much more complex than this but
you get the idea so do this fallback
function will do like this will just say
function alright and we'll say external
payable and we'll just wrap this with
the by token function alright so here's
a new modifier I don't think we've used
yet which is external so that's
different from public because public can
be called you know inside of our smart
contract as well as outside but external
can only be called outside so we don't
want to like call this you know inside
the smart contract somehow so now if we
just compile this again and deploy I'm
gonna paste you wallet in here deploy
we'll see you have a new function just
call fallback and we can basically just
do that like this so we'll just send
money either from a countable one call
the fallback and it worked we can see
our account balance went down this one
up and the balance of first account
should be one yep it's one so now I want
to show you events inside of solidity so
what do we use events for so events are
a way for external consumers to kind of
listen for things that happen on a smart
contract
so basically external consumers can
subscribe to events on a smart contract
and you know wait for something to
happen
so we'll do inside of this by token
function watch e trigger an event that
lets you know anyone connected to the
blockchain really need to know that a
token has been purchased from the smart
contract if they were to listen for it
so I'll create an event like this lit up
here say event purchase and I'll just
say I'll break this line right here
oops I'll say address and know a buyer
and I'll say you went 256 amount okay so
that's how we declare an event just like
that and inside of this function
whenever the token is purchased will
trigger it and we trigger the event like
this I always say emit purchase and we
pass it in the buyer we pass in the
amount so the buyer in this case is MSG
s sender you know the account that's
calling this function and the value in
this case is just one semicolon all
right so there you go now another thing
you can do with these events you can
create an index like this indexed okay
and that will allow you to filter events
that are only from certain buyers so
basically like if you wanted to only
listen to events from the smart contract
that you know a certain person did a
certain account or maybe even just you
you could subscribe based on a specific
address it so I'll show you how that
works
all right let's compile this and run it
I'm going to take the wallet paste it in
here boy all right now I'll call the Buy
its function will send in one either
oops
all right it worked now how we know the
event worked so we can look inside of
this transaction here see the log and we
can see right here here's a log and
inside this law we have some messages
and this basically is is the event we
can see the buyer listed it here and the
amount see the buyer was this address
and here's the amount so what are events
for really there's there's two kind of
main use cases for events you know
because of the asynchronous nature of
the blockchain you know if you're
building an application that I mean if
you're building an application that
talks to the smart contract
you know you might you you might call a
function like by token like if you're
writing a JavaScript application you
might like call this function and then
you know your application would just
know that you called this function but
you might want to actually wait for this
to finish and execute wait for this
event to be emitted so you can basically
wait for that and subscribe to this
event and filter for all the ones you
know that are applicable to you and
whenever that happens you know you can
you can wait for that to happen and then
you know reload your application state
whenever that events been triggered so
that's one popular use case another use
case is you can get the entire event
stream from a smart contract like this
so you can basically see all of the
purchase events because they're you know
listed in these logs they're actually
listed in the transactions you know that
are contained in the blocks of the
blockchain and that's a way to see all
the purchases that have ever happened
inside a smart contract like this
I'll go ahead and use the smart contract
that we were working on in the last
video as the basis for this one so in
this video we're gonna be talking about
how to use multiple smart contracts in
the sloan-c programming language you
know two different aetherium smart
contracts one that will talk to the
other and also show you how to like
write you know parent-child
relationships with smart contracts so
we'll have what about inheritance you
know a contract that inherits from
another one so I'm gonna go ahead and
clear out some of this code from the
last video to kind of get it where we
want it to be the first thing I'll do is
let's see here what basically what we'll
do is well go ahead with this scenario
where we're still gonna buy a token but
instead of you know keeping track of the
balance inside this smart contract will
actually move it to a token contract to
you know kind of separate concerns a
little bit so actually tell you what
let's go ahead and create the token
smart contract like this and again this
is gonna be a really just basic you know
it's almost like pseudocode example it's
not gonna be a full ERC 20 token but
this will just give you an idea of
what's gonna happen when you know two
smart contracts call one another at a
very simple example it'll say contract
your c 20 token and again if you want to
see more you know videos about you 20
tokens i've got plenty on my channel so
i say string name so we're gonna just
have a state variable that keeps track
of the name here it's actually make this
public and we'll do a mapping it'll just
basically move this balances mapping up
here take it out of this contract and
we're going to extract this balances you
know increment here and put it into its
own function so we'll just call this
function mint say function mint i'll
make this public and inside of here
we're just going to do this we'll check
this balances and increment it here just
like that and also we can rewrite this
just say plus plus which way
increment by one refactor that a little
bit make it a little nicer a little
cleaner all right and now you should be
able to clean up this a little bit take
these comments out let's see here let's
actually simplify this we'll take this
purchase event out we don't need all
this that was mostly to show you how
events worked in the last video I just
wanna simplify the code a little bit so
that it's easier to follow along with
alright so inside of here we want to
mint tokens inside of this contract so
you want to call the ERC 20 token from
this by token function so how do we do
that well you know you created this
smart contract in the same file so
because it's in the same file this
contract knows that this contract is
here before we compile it and deploy it
so in the source code you know this one
will know about this one so we can
basically be explicit and tell this
contract if you want to mint tokens in
this contract so in order to do that
there's a couple things that we need we
need to know the address of this
contract which is deployed because you
know this will get deployed and that
this will get deployed and they'll have
two separate addresses and then my
contract needs to know about the ERC 20
token contract where it is and then
we'll basically just reference that
smart contract with the address and
we'll basically get an instance of it
kind of and then we'll just call the
mint function on it all right so there's
a two-step process the first is we need
this contracts address and then we need
to instantiate this contract and then I
guess really the third step is we call
the mint function
so first we'll get access to this token
address we'll say address token all
right we'll make that public so we'll
just say token it's equal to token let
me pass in and we will keep track of it
here
say address token all right we can also
make this public if you wanted to so now
that we have the address we need to
basically get a instance of it so we can
do that like this like I said this
contract source code knows about this er
T 20 token here basically what I'll do
is say I'll create a new one so I can
say Yoshi 20 token all right we're gonna
basically instantiate it and we do that
by passing in the token address that
we've kept track up here so it can be
explicit which I think solidity 0.5
requires us to be explicit so I'll say
address and I'll say token all right so
that will reference this er T 20 token
it's actually deployed it knows about
this source code and then it's going to
get the deployed token from the
blockchain like this and now we can use
this token to call the mint function so
I'll show you a couple ways of doing
this the first one is we can store this
to a variable like this you know when we
create variables and solidity we you
know or whatever declare them we must
specify the type first so the type is
gonna be a RC 20 token contract and this
is a local variable it's on a state
variable so I'm gonna prepend it with an
underscore just kind of a convention
token it's not necessary for solidity
but I do this a lot you'll see this you
know all over the place and now we can
mint the token like this we just say
token that mints
all right so now we can call this by
token function from this smart contract
and it will you know use this you'll
call them it function to from the smart
contract so let's check it out all right
we'll run it so first we have to deploy
this in two steps since there's two
smart contracts in this file we'll pull
the ERC 20 token contract first we'll
deploy it I'm sorry I'm actually going
to use the JavaScript VM will deploy it
all right and now we can just copy the
address of the smart contract that was
deployed
down here from the transaction receipt
let's say contract address and then now
we'll go to my contract and deploy it so
it's asking for a wallet and a token
address let's paste in the token address
the second argument the first argument
I'll just get the wallet so I'll just
copy the basically this is the second
account from here so we'll do this
account all right I deploy okay and now
call the buy token function boom y'all
see the token address here and now we'll
say take the balance of our current
address that we're connected with to see
if it worked all right so why is that
why is it zero well I'll show you why
well first it was successful the buy
tokens function works it actually did
call them in function here but it's
confusing because our you know balance
from the account that we did it with is
wrong so I'll show you what's right all
right so let's go let's don't let you
guess as to why this might be wrong well
instead of leaving a suspense it's got
to do with msg got sender here okay so
this can be a real gacho in your
programming and solidity and you want to
call you know a smart contract function
from another smart contract so earlier
when we built this we call this meant
function directly like if we go here and
click mint right and now I click balance
it goes up by one but if we do it from
here you know we can click it again by
token
let me see it's working but our balance
doesn't increase at all but if I could
do mint here it does increase
that's because msg got sender in this
case is
the address of the contract that called
the function not who sent it
okay now that's kind of tricky so we can
actually get the address of the person
who sent the initial transaction instead
of MSG sender we also have access to TX
top origin all right and that will
actually meant functions for whoever
initiate you know initiated this
transaction so if we call MIT function
direct on the smart contract
it'll increment our balance and if we
call from the smart contract it'll also
increment the balance of the person who
called this by token function so that's
a real gotcha when you're you know
programming multiple smart contracts and
solidity that I wanted you to know about
now I'll show you how this works
so I'll deploy the token first we'll
deploy it all right and I'm going to
deploy you know my contract next say my
contract and we'll paste in the address
okay it'll be the wall address and we'll
also paste in the smart contract address
like this it would apply it now let's
try to buy tokens again do buy token all
right it worked so now let's go look at
balances of this account we're connected
to you know account three three see this
is account three three see their balance
and it's one if we mint tokens here as
well it also increases so that's how TX
origin works you know it's different
from MSG dot sender it's always the
person who originated the transaction
even if a smart contract is calling the
function so what are you all know that
because if that's like definitely can be
a gotcha whenever you are programming
smart contracts that talk to one another
all right so I'll show you one other
thing before we move on just shorthand
here so whenever we mint this token we
can just do this
we can we don't destroy this token as a
variable we can just say he or she 20
token and then just call them in
function on it directly like this and
that was the exact same thing so I want
to walk you through all that but I just
wanted to show you that that's also a
nice clean shorthand valid way of
writing this in one line instead of do
okay so now I do want to talk about the
next topic which is how to inherit smart
contract so inheritance so having a
parent and a child relationship now a
creative token that inherits from this
basic you know a 20 token to do two
things so we'll keep this functionality
the same and what we'll do is basically
give out you know give this token you
know the second token down here we'll
give it its own characteristic so we'll
give it its own name and we'll also
override some of the minting functions
to you know why aren't some of our own
behavior in our own sort of pseudo token
that we're gonna create so I'll say my
token all right so that's what this will
be and this mile thick them will inherit
from this one and we do basic
inheritance just like this we just say
is ERC 20 token
so let's customize this token I mean the
first thing you could do is basically
over I the name because a string a
public name we could set it to something
you know default like my token right and
that would technically override this
right it would be basic inheritance
because we define it a second time it
would override whatever's in this parent
class or parent contract and that shows
you how that works but it doesn't really
give us a whole lot of extra
functionality so let's show you how this
works in a different way so I'll set the
name inside this parent contract like
this will say constructor say string
memory name say public you know say name
equals name right so basically we'll
just have a constructor function that's
realm of this corner just Boyd and we'll
take a name and we'll set it to the
state variable here
so we can actually override this
whenever we deploy our own smart
contract like this we can say instead of
just storing having the hard value we
can also inherit that we do like this
instructor string memory C name and I
can say er C 20 token name and that'll
pass the name in from this constructor
along to this alright and we'll just say
public let's say we also wanted our
token to have a symbol just say string
memory oops
symbol okay and we'll just say symbol
equals to symbol almost say a string
public symbol all right so that's a way
for us to accept our own you know
argument into our own constructor but
still take constructor parameters from
the parent contract and I'm gonna break
this up like this to make it a little
easier to read I do this a lot in my you
know production smart contracts I break
up the lines like this so it's easier to
read alright so that's how you you know
override constructors like that now
inside a few let's override this mint
function as well okay let's basically
add some extra behavior we want to
preserve this mint function we still
want to keep track of the balance but we
also want to do some extra let's keep
track of the people who actually own the
tokens
so first we'll say I will keep you an
array of owners will say address some e
array of addresses say public owners all
right and then we'll say we'll keep it
counter cash and the people who own the
token this is a you int do 56 owner
account all right and now we will update
these values in our own men function so
we're gonna create a mint function that
basically preserves the functionality of
this but add some additional behavior so
we say that is going to be function mint
so we're gonna go ride it say public
okay so first thing we want to do is
call this mint function so that this you
know behavior is preserved we just say
super mint all right and now we say
owner count plus plus let me say owners
push MSG descender okay and that is
basically going to call the minute
function the parent contract to update
the balances then it'll increment the
number of people who own the token right
here and it will add them to the array
of owners okay all right so now let's
just compile it run it and so when we do
this we don't have to deploy to smart
contracts all we have to do is deploy
this one so you can say you're actually
20 token I'll see the string actually
let's do this let's do my token so
string name will be my token and symbol
will be empty kay deploy all right
so let's call them in function all right
worked so let's see the balances of the
current the current address that we're
connected with will say balance is this
okay all right we'll do the name my
token and the owners of the first person
and the lists is our address and a
symbol okay alright and we can also make
this public if you want to read the
owner count all right guys so that's how
you inherent smart contracts and
solidity
I'm gonna be talking about two different
topics in this video that are somewhat
related the first topic is libraries how
to use them in solidity and the second
topic is math you know how to do math in
the solidity programming language and
these are somewhat related because you
know we use libraries to manage math
functions all the time and solidity is a
really common use case so I figured I
would just record both of those in the
same video so you know what is a library
or if not familiar you know library is
basically a way to organize code that
can be reused in multiple places inside
your project so that's one of the main
reasons we use libraries is essentially
to dry code up so if you're not familiar
with dry Droy that's an acronym for
don't repeat yourself alright so
basically if we have a function that we
want to use in multiple smart contracts
we could define inside of a library and
then use that library to use that
function and that way if that function
ever changes the change is absorbed by
any place that we use it so how do we
declare a library in solidity well like
this first we use the library keyword
state library and I'm gonna call this
library just math
okay
so in the earlier videos you know I said
that you know smart contracts are the
main way that we organize code inside of
solidity you know it's call it contract
oriented language and that's true but we
also have libraries where we can you to
find functions inside of here and store
variables and things like that and
that's another way to organize code
inside solidity but really at the end of
the day a library belongs you know
inside of the smart contracts that you
can get called and used you know
libraries don't have the full behavior
of a smart contract they don't really
have storage in and of themselves they
don't you know you can't inherit from a
library things like that so it's not
really like a smart contract at the end
of the day it's meant to be used inside
of a smart contract so we can define a
function inside a library like this I'm
going to create my own divide function
say function divided alright I'll just
leave this here for a second so why we
want to use divide function well I'll
show you let's create an example inside
of my contract where we would you know
basically just do some math first of all
will declare a value will say you at 256
say public value will just store the
value here and now actually store this
value but will will compute it
so we'll say function I'll say calculate
and we'll take a value say you int will
say value 1
so you nth value to say public and
inside of here well basically just set
the value to whatever the calculated
value is we'll say a value 1
/ by YouTube now this is a basic way to
do division inside solidity we just use
this operator here it's the division
operator so why might we want to use a
library for this
well you might notice a problem it's
value to what if value to is zero right
there be a problem with this we get some
sort of exception because you know we
can't divide by zero
and that's a really common use case for
a library basically we can write some
code inside of here that prevents this
divided by zero error we can actually
stop the function before that happens so
basically we could do like this we could
define this function and say divide is
equal to you know the input say you int
256 let's just say a you went 256
B was a internal pure turns
you had 256 it will do the division
inside of here so you require that be
it's greater than zero that's the first
thing we'll do we'll take the
denominator and make sure the
denominator is greater than zero so that
we don't divide by zero then we'll
actually create a return value of C
which is C divided by B or the numerator
divided by the denominator and we'll
just return that value return C sorry
this is supposed to be a so now we can
actually use this divide instead of this
divide here as a safer way to do
division inside of solidity that's a
really common use case for a library so
how do we do that how do we take this
function out of this library and use it
inside this calculate function like this
well we can say math dot divide and then
just pass in value one and value two and
we store the output to value just like
that all right now erase this all right
now let's try to run this code
so whenever we deploy this I'm gonna
select my contract and instead of math
and whenever this is to compiled and
deployed it knows that my contract
depends upon math so it's already gonna
get compiled and deploy automatically we
don't have to deploy this first and then
this this and the whole compilation
process of this file the math library at
least the part that gets used is gonna
get compiled because it's dependent upon
right here so let's try this first we
can see the value is zero and we'll say
value one is I'll say 100 and value 2 is
10 all right okay no successful you see
the value is 10 now and as we try to
divide by 0 calculate and we get an
error just as we expect you know we can
also do some other values just to make
sure it works
say 144 divided by 12 should also be 12
yep all right so that's how you you know
it's a basic example of how you import a
math function from a library now there
are a few other ways we can do this you
know instead of having this library just
at the top or a file here we can
actually move it to another file and
import it inside of this file so we can
clean this up and we're only looking at
one you know sort of unit at a time we
like to look at the smart contract we
don't have to look at this library so I
should I to do that we'll go over here
to our browser and we'll create a new
file I'll call this math does so well
all right now we'll just copy the math
library from here I'll actually just
copy it with the solidity programming
language declaration and we'll paste it
in here save
now we can require the file just like
this we say import we use double quotes
math so well alright
and unless I use the dot to indicate the
current directory forward slash and the
filename which is math the SOL followed
by semicolon
alright that'll be the same thing so we
can go back to here and deploy this same
math it's alright go to my contract and
deploy and we'll see say one eighty
eight and nine
all right there we go that's doing an
integer division that's why it's has no
remainder
okay so that's how you import a library
from another file and slow to you now
I'll show you one more thing I want to
introduce you to a really common library
which is called safe math which just put
out by open Zeppelin you can go that
repository here if you want to read more
about it but basically it implements a
lot of helpful functions that I use a
lot but developing smart contracts and
doing math they've you know they've
solved a lot of problems like guarding
from overflow and things like that and
so I use this library a lot so it's
really common use case from me I'm going
to show you how to use that library
inside of here because it works a little
bit differently than how we implemented
our math library so I'm going to delete
this file and create a new one say safe
math
I'm just gonna copy the code here from
github click Edit
and go starting to edit I wanna do raw
I'm just gonna copy all that go back to
remix and paste this in here
alright let's actually change the salute
your programming language of version
shows you're about 5.1 i think it should
probably be up to date
oops
yeah looks good all right so let's save
that go back to my contract instead of
importing math we'll do safe math
all right and instead of you know
calling a library like this we're gonna
do a different way all right and this is
pretty cool so we can take all these
functions in here like multiply and
divide and subtract and add we can
actually call them on unsigned integers
directly all right and we developed this
we can say using safe math for you int
256 all right now that's pretty cool
I'll show you what that does instead of
doing this we can basically say value 1
give value 2
there you go that's pretty slick so
let's try that
go Mike on track with a ploy like this
so he value wine will be 144 yeah I 2 is
12
all right value it's 12
there we go say 13333 right by 11
yeah 100/10
there we go awesome all right so that's
all I got for this video today guys
again you can find all the code examples
of this on my website over at DAP
university comm ford slash article
forward slash solidity tutorial I'll put
a link to that down the description
below and again if you're serious about
becoming a blotching developer and you
enjoy my free training on my website
over at Dappy diversity comm forward
slash bootcamp alright until next time
thanks for watching dap University